ça lui fait mal pour brut quand j'achète
mon matos je pense je dois être l'été de
mes 17 ans ou 18 ans je sais pas je
travaille à bricoman cause dédicaces
mais que de bricoman d'aulnay-sous-bois
et va dire je travaillais la première
année un mois j'ai dû acheter ma tour le
micro la carte son et la deuxième année
j'y suis retourné et j'ai amélioré tout
ça et vas-y c'est sûr ça a changé ma vie
puisque j'ai travaillé pour acheter ce
matériel premier m'a tout ce que j'ai
acheté j'ai acheté un vrai pc avec une
vraie config onfray informaticiens
évidemment qu'il va aider vrai config
vrai micro vraie carte son
j'ai encore mon micro incroyable un
artefact rares j'ai fait mon premier mix
tape dessus dans ma chambre à la maison
loisirs on a fait une quinzaine tm
gamecube et on a fait cours de
rattrapage aussi et encore plein de sons
j'enregistrais trophée avec cette config
lac était sorti son carton après
j'arrête et l'enjeu trait là dessus
mersen c'est incroyable c'était omise
mise
il va y avoir 60 personnes à les 80
soyons fous c'était complètement barjo
les mecs qui venait juste sur une ktm
quelqu'un b est assez chaude première
scène dans un bar incroyable maxime
souvenir ça ça a changé ma vie d'un coup
je me suis quand même
ok fait de la musique dans notre champ
mais les gens y viennent pour l'écouter
c'était ouf c ur moi ça veut dire
quelque chose tu vois là ça veut dire
quelque chose quand bien même tu as des
chiffres sur internet et vues des
machins s'est pas vraiment palpable
voilà vas-y premier concert c'était ouf
[Musique]
j'ai été père c'est un peu balourd et
tout le monde le dit mais non je dirais
la première fois que tu as menée à
disneyland
ouais quand je l'amenais disneyland en
vip et qu'on faisait pas la queue et
qu'on avait un guide une fréquence et le
train de la mine en boucle ouais c'est
incroyable ça a changé ma vie
lui il a 5 ans et l'a jamais fait la
queue de sa vie et je te jure il s'agace
et des fois on attendait une minute et
j'aurais l'arrivée à s'agacer or vous
accordez c'est un sacré moment dans une
vie quand même même pour moi c'est un
freestyle un peu facile juste avec une
mélopée incroyable ah ouais ouais faut
pas sous-estimer la ouais ouais c'est
une sacrée incantations consacré
sortilèges ouais ça ça change lui parce
que là c'est vraiment un gros tube quoi
ah ça y est on a été joué dans les clubs
ça nous a envoyé un showcase partout
dans la france j'ai l'impression de
faire la musique de merde c'est la
musique la plus relâchée que je fais la
plus cool en fait genre vraiment
désaccordé ouais pas à dire que c'est de
la merde mais vraiment je suis un
freestyle conseil
rappel vld ok pour moi c'est très facile
et paf
le premier exemple que j'ai c'est
bonjour je vois pour moi ces gens ultra
facile et paf c'est complètement fou on
a une liste de tubes qui devait pas être
des tubes c'est barjots je pensais
vraiment quelque chose quand tu
abandonnes les enjeux je pense c'est un
truc de pression tu mets trop de trop de
pression trop dangereux tueur et
cérébrales il trop ta merde en fait
et du coup la magie passe moins bien et
quand tu dis on vraiment que c'est nul
tu réfléchis plus à rien et là bas je
pense est avec moi sur scène je comble
azadé c'est sûr que c'est un sacré
moment de vie de rencontres et 1 seconde
ouais on est en dst il ya un mec je sais
pas ce qu'ils racontent et genre il est
sur la tête
ad je connais même pas et il dit c'est
dans un silence fracassant
j'étais fan tout de suite sur ce manga
de l'école on se rend compte en secondes
et vazimba au début on fait des sketches
en fait nos trucs nous c'était de
rigoler et ça nous faisait rire de faire
des sketches et des vidéos des courts
métrages on faisait n'importe quoi on
était des youtube eur en 2009 un truc
comme ça et vas-y 1 on s'achetait notre
premier caméscope on faisait nos
premiers sketchs non machin et après le
rapt arrivée dans votre vie c'est vrai
que ça a changé ma vie parce que l'on
s'est retrouvé au théâtre trévise à
l'ayguade et où il faut des scènes
ouvertes et tout est en fait on n'a fait
rire personne c'était terrible c'était
une absence de rire de cinq minutes cinq
ou six mouthe
avant tu fait encore froid dans le dos
najim rdr koné dit viens on fait du rap
[Musique]
quand on a fini ce monde est cruel je
pense que ça a vraiment changé notre vie
pourquoi ça a changé notre vie ça a
changé ma vie
parce que je pense que j'ai une équipe
de perfectionniste qui ce qui cérébrale
is eux aussi énormément et on a tous
très envie de bien faire et c'est la
première fois qu'on avait autant de
temps pour faire de la musique genre
aussi émis de janvier à août
c'est quand même pas mal et pendant un
long moment il y avait beaucoup de
questions y avait beaucoup de doutes et
a eu beaucoup de attend mais est ce que
est ce que beaucoup de dévalorisation a
pour tout le monde
et soudain on a fini l'album est alors
voilà il nous a fallu quand même
peut-être une semaine je dirais pour se
rendre compte qu'on avait essayé quelque
chose qui nous couvre de tous et dont on
était très contents et la plus des
valorisations plus de we take un fumiste
donc je pense quand on a fini seulement
des cruelles il s'est passé quelque
chose
c'est fou quand même parce que on a la
même équipe depuis cinq six projets et
du coup on se connaît et ça n'arrête pas
de fonctionner de mieux en mieux et on
arrive quand même à être en mode ou 1
c'est nul je pense pas que ça va marcher
je pense qu'on peut mieux faire j'ai pas
confiance
c'est terrible de vivre c'est notre
huitième croit on est des professionnels
vaud